Weedle edges of Chamberlain height you
want a bad one to fondle your balls and
check out our top 9 o movie line you're
trying to pee Basketball Diaries and get
up on this leonardo de Mestre outskirts
I got hold ring are you let me hit that
coffee with my cream ah
hey mom do you want Amanda money's
ticking wrong with you want a Netflix
and chilling with some Hoosiers
and take some of my Jimmy Chitwood
trying to milk you to butter rim ah you
want to finish with my sick man ah c'est
beau you trying to get your space jam in
your face team white men can't jump and
they can't huh so why don't you let a
real man Doug of all Yoho
Billy how ha you shouldn't swallow these
blue chips okay really
hell naw
you